- Every child has the right to graduate
with an "I Can" mindset.
You meet a child anywhere in the world
they go from crawling
to standing to running
to thinking to laughing and just when
they're telling the world,
"Look at me, I can!"
We send them to school.
(laughs) And you say, "Oh, you can run?
"Sorry, you have to sit out.
"You can think and talk?
"Tsk, tsk, tsk, that's
wrong; you have to listen."
That is what I encountered
first-hand with my child
so I took him out of school.
I said, "I can do a better job."
(students talking)
So when I took him out
I don't think it was
with a big story of changing
the world or you know,
changing education and all of that.
It was just my child.
And at that time I was
running a design firm.
The fact that I didn't come from education
I was not bothered by the size
of what I was setting out to do.
So that's really what
allowed me to be audacious.
(students and teacher talking)
(students laughing)
- Good morning, thank you.
- Good morning.
- As a designer, I was very
inspired by design thinking.
(laughing)
So to start by questioning the status quo
is what design thinking tells us to do.
It starts with empathy;
it starts with the user.
Who is it for?
What does success look like?
Okay, and then what should I
do to ensure that I achieve it?
So for the longest time education has made
the parent the primary stakeholder.
Parent wants exam.
Parent wants homework.
Parent wants this.
Children became incidental to the program.
When you put the child
back front and center,
they will shape the story.
- Good morning, everyone.
It's time for the shout-outs.
- Our children became
a designer's write off.
They designed the uniform.
They became clients for the architect.
It was a genuine collaboration.
It was just that belief
that it's your space.
(talking and laughing)
We are crafting the final curriculum.
We want you to graduate
with the idea of "I Can".
- We know that we are
responsible for our own learning
so that's (mumbles)
- Today we offer a
curriculum that is built
on design thinking framework.
If you look at every design process,
they will have ideate, explore,
define, prototype, product.
But we simplified it.
We call it FIDS: Feel, Imagine, Do, Share.
- Okay, Aleah is gonna make the uniform
which can be used?
- Both the sides.
- To understand what they
might be going through,
what can we do?
- Three, two, one, go!
Keep going guys!
Keep going, keep going, keep going!
(cheering and laughing)
- So for 15 years if they use the same
design thinking framework, they graduate
with an "I Can" mindset.
This belief that I can do it.
So I think that idea of
questioning the status quo
is what we need to do in education.
We don't realize that
the choice can be us.
That we are who we've been waiting for.
That is the mindset we owe our children
so they shine and they thrive.
That's what I wanna give to every child.
(children laughing)